تندلع حروب عملات من وقت لاخر يكون الطرف
المحارب فيها هو الدولار واطراف القتال
متعدده اخرها الصين والبرازيل بعد
اعلانهما تخليهما عن الدولار الامريكي
اتفاق يتيح للصين ثاني عملاق تجاري واكبر
منافس للهيمنه الاقتصاديه الامريكيه
والبرازيل اكبر اقتصاد في امريكا
اللاتينيه وشريك التجاريه الاكبر للصين
اجراء صفقاتهما التجاريه الهائله مباشره
واستبدالها بالعمله المحليه
فالتبادل التجاري بينهما قدر ب150 مليار
دولار في العام الماضي فقط
على الجانب الاخر حرب اقتصاديه تدور راحها
في ساحه اخرى هي روسيا والمحارب فيها هو
الدولار الامريكي ايضا
موسكو لم تتخذ فقط من اوكرانيا ساحه حرب
لها بل بالتوازي استخدمت اسواق العالم ارض
حرب اخرى سلع روسيا فيها ضد امريكا ليس
عسكريا بل تجاري
تجاريا اتخذت موسكو سلاح الروبل للحد من
استخدام الدولار في معاملاتها الدوليه حتى
الطاقه كانت احد اسلحه روسيا الفعاله في
مارس الماضي اصدرت موسكو مرسوما يقضي ببيع
الغاز والنفط للدول غير الصديقه حصرا
بالروبل
كما انها عززت من علاقاتها الخارجيه خاصه
مع الصين الصديق التاريخي لها تجمعهما
مساء لم تعد خفيه تاسيس نظام دولي جديد لا
يعتمد على الدولار كعمله رئيسيه في
التبادلات التجاريه والماليه اما الهند
الشريك الوطيد لروسيا فسبق ان اعلنت العام
الماضي عن اتفاق ثنائي باستخدام عملتيهما
المحليتين في التبادل التجاري بينهما
الخزانه الامريكيه ترى ان كسر هيمنه
الدولار امر صعب جدا فيما اخرون يحذرون من
تداعياته
فمحاولات اضعاف الدولار قد تعني نظاما
نقديا اكثر تشتتا ومجاميع تجاريه منفصله
بتكتلات عملات صغيره روان حمزه العربيه